we covered the idea of vector length
vector length many many videos ago and I
realized that I forgot to cover an
important topic and this topic is going
to be useful when we do some types of
transformations actually the projections
that I'll do in the next video and the
notion that I forgot to do is the notion
of a unit vector unit vector and all
this is is a vector this is just a
vector that has a length of 1 so let me
see has length and we've defined length
it has a length of 1 so if something is
a unit vector let's say that you right
here is a unit vector and it can and
it's a member of RN it's a member of RN
then that means that if we have u u
looks like this has n components u 2 all
the way to u n we know what the length
of this is right the length of this the
definition of the length we know that
the length of U sometimes called the
norm of U it's just equal to the square
root of the squared sums of all of its
components and if you think about it
this is just an extension of the
Pythagorean theorem to some degree but
so it's u1 squared plus u2 squared all
the way to u n squared and it's the
square root of that if this is a unit
vector if this is a unit vector so this
is a unit vector unit vector that
implies that the length of U will be
equal to 1 and that doesn't matter in
what dimension space we are this could
be our 100 this could be our two for it
to have a unit vector in any of those
pieces spaces their length is one so the
next obvious question is how do you
construct a unit vector so let's say
that I have some vector V and let's say
it's not a unit vector so it's v1 v2 all
the way to VN and I want to turn it into
some vector u that is a unit vector that
just goes in the same direction so you
we'll go in the same direction same
direction as V but just has a length the
length of U is going to be equal to 1
how do i construct this vector u here
well what I could do is I could take the
length of V I could find out what the
length of V is and we know how to do
that we just apply this definition of
vector length and what happens if I
figure out the length of V and then I
multiply the vector V times that so what
if I make my U
what if I say U is equal to 1 over the
length of V 1 over the length of V times
V itself what happens here if I take the
length of this thing right here if I
take the length of that what do I get so
this is so the length of U is equal to
the length of this scalar remember this
is just some number right it's equal to
this scalar and I'm assuming V is a
nonzero vector so the length of this
lowers whatever this scalar number is
times V and we know that we can take
this scalar out of the formula we could
show that I think I've shown it in a
previous video that the length of C
times V is equal to C times the length
of V let me write that down and that's
essentially what I'm assuming right here
that if I take the length of C times
some vector V that is equal to C times
the length of V I think we showed this
when we first were introduced to the
idea of length so we know that this is
going to be equal to 1 over the length
of vector V that's my C times so this
thing right here is that thing right
there
times this thing times the length of
vector V well what's this going to be
equal to 1 over something times that's
something well this is just going to be
equal to 1 so that's all a unit vector
is if you want to find a unit vector or
sometimes it's called a normalized
vector it's nice to another
normalized normalized vector that goes
in the same direction as some vector V
you just figure out the length of V just
using the definition of vector length in
RN and then multiply one over that
length times the vector V and this is
just a scalar and then you get your
vector you let me do an example just to
make sure you get the idea so let's say
I have some vector let's say I have some
vector V let's say I have some vector V
and it's in r3 let's say it's 1 2 minus
1 what is the length of V the length of
V is equal to the square root of 1
squared plus 2 squared plus minus 1
squared minus 1 squared and that is
equal to the square root of what 1 plus
1 plus 4 square root of 6 so that is the
length of V so if I want to construct a
normalized vector U that goes in the
same direction as V I just take I can
just define my vector U as being equal
to 1 over the length of V 1 over the
square root of 6 times V so times 1 2
minus 1 which is equal to 1 over square
root of 6 2 over the square root of 6
and minus 1 over the square root of 6
and I'll leave it for you to verify that
the length of U is going to be equal to
1 and I'll just draw it one other idea
here that you'll often see when
something is a unit vector instead of
using this little arrow on top of the
vector they'll often write a unit vector
with a little hat on top of it like that
that signifies that we're dealing with a
unit vector and for those of you who've
taken your vector calculus or I've done
a little bit of engineering you're
probably familiar with the vectors I J
and K and the reason why they have this
little hat here is because these are all
unit vectors in r3 there are n members
of our three and they're all unit
vectors these are actually the basis
vectors in r3
for those of you all have been watching
my transformation videos these are
equivalent to the vectors e1 which I
could write with a hat on it really eetu
and e3 which are the standard basis
vectors in r3 anyway now that you've
been exposed to it now I can start to
use the idea of a unit vector in future
videos